is there such thing as female privilege
i feel like privilege what's that mean
like is there such thing like do you
know there's male privilege is there
such thing as female privilege
you still haven't explained i don't
understand you like are there are there
privileges that are afforded to women
that aren't afforded to men
in a way yeah yeah
are there any double standards in
relationships that don't favor women
not really
no i agree i agree um why are men taught
how to treat a woman but women aren't
taught how to treat a man
well men treat
first of all men treat women better than
women treat boys in my perspective yeah
why do you think that is
from experience
like from experience like first first
experience like like men bringing out a
girl to like a restaurant treat her all
the best bring her to fulfill whatever
for drinks and then the boy
does all that and the girls still go out
and cheats on them
do you think there's a lack of
accountability for women like for
example um jada smith who do you know
who jada smith is will smith's
how she cheated with a drug addict that
was 20 years younger than her and do you
think if will smith did the same thing
it would be perceived differently
isn't that interesting
yeah yeah he's a boy and he'd be he be
labeled as a [ __ ] boy
um what are some women's issues
cheating
texting all the boys
no no like women's rights issues like
women's rights
rights yeah like i'm not really in i'm
not really into writing all that stuff
okay i wouldn't be like into that you
can't name any no none no okay is there
a such thing as female privilege
well
guys say yes but i said no
like the privilege they say is like you
don't pay entrance for going to a club
and that's all
what about like sentencing disparities
in like like in the criminal justice
system like men get three times the
sentence for the same crime
um i also think it's like uh
the systematical violence
and
misogynistic education make uh
men to
are more probable to commit crime and
also with more violence so i think
there's a structural reason why it's not
like because they're women it's like
very plain answer no i agree men are
more disagreeable so they tend to like
commit more crimes than women but my
question is like for when women commit
the same crime they get men get three
times the sentence that women do i don't
know if it works like that in mexico i'm
not sure is it
is there such thing as female privilege
uh
the privilege do you mean that it's
better to be
yeah i think some what are some examples
of female privilege
i mean
in my country it's a bit
more than here but
in general you know that's like
man should give more attention to a
woman paying for some stuff most of the
time
where are you from i'm from ukraine and
was it more traditional there yeah
they're more like
old-fashioned and this kind of stuff do
you think that's better or worse for
relationships
i mean it's hard for me to answer
because i was like you know raised like
this so it's normal it's kind of how it
should be
and
um
i think it's better because it's making
me feel like more you know female and
that
i feel that someone care for me
but people are different for someone
it's good to have like you know partners
more things do you i agree with you like
i kind of like it when like you feel
like you're taken care of a little bit
yeah and i almost think it's like lost a
little bit in today
uh yeah i mean uh it's always it's still
50 50 but in other stuff like our
woman's are more like
cooking carrying you know
bringing stuff trying to make
like home more cozy you know this more
female things so
it's still not like oh man's doing
everything and girls just taking it's
just in other stuff it's not like
fair partners we just take everything
half and half it's just this more female
thing to this more male thing so um why
are men taught how to treat women but
women aren't taught how to treat men or
do you feel like that's not the case in
mexico because i'm from the us so there
might be some cultural like differences
yeah i think actually uh
when you grow up as a mexican girl your
moms are always telling how to uh behave
in front of men
so it exists yeah and there's a lot of
uh
behind the table rules so it's like
nobody speak about it but it's there for
girls too yes so what is it like what do
they teach you um well the basic one uh
don't
have relationships like sexual
relationship with if you want to like
get serious with him
for example
i don't know
the guy has to pay the bill if he is
interested in you but you always have to
get money so if he is like
i don't know
whatever happens you have to be prepared
yeah oh so i um
do you think that's helpful like have
you found it helpful in your life to
know these things or do you feel like it
hasn't been helpful the last one yes the
first one no
oh the first one now no i am actually i
think my three last boyfriends i
uh first
made him like that way and then we say
oh like yeah why not we can be
boyfriends and girlfriends it's kind of
like a different world now than it was
in the old age you know what i mean it
has changed but i also have to say that
i'm from a big city i'm from the capital
and it works very different in the
capital than outside the capital
what are some what are some women's
issues uh they have a problem with men
going out with their other friends
when they always go away with you they
never actually talk to you
those are women's issues oh wait no
women's issues is
when you go out to your machine they
think that you're going out to older
girls
they get angry when they're on their
period
and
they get angry over little teens and you
don't want to be on the phone with them
um what can you name any men's issues
we hate when girls are out with boys
uh we have to put up with stress and
football
yeah i'm i'm engaged by gopros we have
loads anxiety
what are some double standards today
between men and women you know do you
know not know what double standards
means i mean it's like
they related like
i don't know it just means like um
like a man does one thing and a woman
does one thing and there's a double
standard so people look at it
differently all right so
you go first uh
when
men cheat on women or women treat your
men
they look at it differently how do they
look at it differently and the women
look at it differently like they've been
saying like a lot of lesson girls but
the man looks at like these things
saying one man and what is the worst
date you've ever been on i met this guy
in a party and i was thinking like we
are going to i don't know like going for
a walk and then it's something or i
don't know ice cream whatever date thing
and
uh he was living in the north of the
city and i'm very far away from the
north
and he just we a point like in the
middle point and he uh drive me to his
car to his place and he only want to
like
go straight for the thing like nothing
like it was very accurate there was a
lot of awkward uh silence there and
i just never see him again because it
was too weird because he was he was just
being too pushy with like sex yes
actually with the sex he was very like
maybe he was more explicit about it i
will say like yes or no but he was like
implicitly pushing too much and i was
like if you are going to be like that
yeah at least have the guts to say it
like it straight away you know yeah so i
can prepare and they made another
decision like maybe i was like oh yes or
maybe no thanks yeah no that's that's
the worst is when guys are so pushy and
they don't like leave you alone about
and and it's like if they just had the
balls to say it then maybe we could like
make a decision yeah actually i think
that's one of the main things that i
always say to my friends my male friends
like say
what you want maybe you will get the yes
maybe not but at least you're saving
voda's time you know okay do you think
that is dating different in mexico to
like europe to do you live in ireland
now yes um is dating different would you
say here versus in mexico yeah is it
more traditional in mexico i think
i think in ireland it's more traditional
than but i i'm from the big city again
right so i think
maybe it's because of the it's maybe a
cliche but the
latino heat and warmth and openness with
that
and maybe it's because i'm also an
artist and my circle is like very
open-minded i have a lot of friends that
get tattoos and are like uh legalized
marijuana all that thing maybe it's just
my circle but that's my perception
all i have because i feel like how old
are you guys you're 12.
do you guys have you been on a date yet
yeah yeah
you've been on loads of dates yeah now
in this pizza shop that it's my main
place with ladies
wait when when did you go on your first
date
when i was known uh when i was 10. is
that normal in ireland
it's it's normal in dublin now in
ireland well one morning we made went
down when he was when he was eight i
think
did you pay for the date
no she paid for hortans i pitched from
one
she split it
that's so manly not yet
i don't i don't like to like
i don't i don't like to share stuff with
women
where anyone really
what are some women's issues
um
i think
we are most of the time like too
emotional and we think it's fine it's
how it should be you know that everyone
should understand it and they can't
charge us by this
so yeah
um
why
i don't know if this is the case in um
in the ukraine yeah but in the like west
typically more why are men taught how to
treat a woman but women aren't taught
how to treat men
um i know children say like what give me
examples
so from a young age at least in the so
i'm from the u.s everyone's taught like
you should like the men should pay for
the dates like the men should like take
care of women but women aren't taught
what to do for men like if we're told to
cook clean that's like seen as bad yeah
yeah oh yeah it's true
i mean europe is more like this yeah
like the woman is independent and
uh no one should say the stuff but she's
still enjoying what the guy doing this
thing so it's like the yeah the game on
the one you know one way game so i like
this part so let's leave it but i don't
like this one so let's move it and um
yeah i mean everything i said before
everything should be fair if you want
something like this like manual stuff
you should take like girl strolls things
as well for example like i'm not
cleaning i hate cleaning but i try to do
more like for example cooking or
also like help him with like closer
things what he don't like i mean it's
it's always worked differently you know
a different relationship but you can
find excuse but it's unfair to say that
like yeah do you think women only care
about double standards when they don't
benefit them
yeah kind of
um okay so question you're from ireland
is is dating more traditional or modern
here it's not even they just go out and
[ __ ] the next girl you see that's how it
is here people don't really do
relationships but if you do you get
[ __ ] over really so it's like very
casual here very casual like people like
i have a friend from germany she said
from her area you don't see that stuff
happening
but here it's such a casual thing like
you get
like people say oh well done like oh
you're such a legend for like cheating
on your girlfriend
really so everything's like do you think
men are afraid of marriage nowadays and
commitment or do you think it's the
women depends on their past like if they
got cheated on in the past obviously
they're gonna be yeah the commitment
issues is gonna be like up there yeah
like for me as well like i'm not gonna
get another girl for about five years
yeah after i got cheated on so yeah
i mean what is the difference between a
woman playing hard to get and not being
interested
um
no i actually don't know no i actually
don't know do you think women ever flirt
for attention yeah definitely do you
think that makes it confusing for men
no because i think men do it too you
think men do it too yeah definitely do
you think the majority of men can flirt
for attention
no
no no i mean they only think they can um
yeah no i think both sides do it i think
sometimes it's just if you're bored
people do it or if they want a bit of
attention they do it
so i'm in ireland now and i'm so nervous
to ask people i don't know how they
receive okay okay okay
um
hi would you guys want to do a public
interview for a youtube channel
yeah public interview
oh no no okay that's okay um
hi do you want to do a public interview
no
let's see
let's see let's see let's see
okay okay
hi would you want to do a public
interview for a youtube channel oh no
thank you okay you're okay
let me stop recording um are there any
double standards in relationships that
don't favor women
and
i think there's a massive narrative that
women have to be
controlling or maybe even have
boundaries for their boyfriends but and
then as soon as they don't have that
and
people think they're you know trying to
just please their boyfriend but i think
it's more just letting them do what they
want and being an autonomous can i have
an example of that
and maybe like letting them go on a
night out with their friends
like that kind of thing like there's
like people think they're cheating you
think yeah or like even i feel like
girls can kind of
get surprised or even be like
why are you letting them go on a night
out when it's just you know you're just
letting them be their own person i guess
yeah no i agree um
dude what are what are women's issues
are those loads in terms of like
societal issues yeah could you just name
like one or two women's issues and
gender pay gap
[Music]
and societal pressures to have kids
um can you name any men's issues
um
not being able to be emotionally
vulnerable
okay
and probably pressure to be a
breadwinner or to support a family okay
it's interesting because most people i
ask they like can't name any men's
issues yeah so it's like interesting how
one seems to be at least in the u.s like
pushed or the other doesn't would you
agree with that
yeah i probably would say that there's a
lot more emphasis on women's issues just
because the equality
inequality is there but it definitely
doesn't mean that men don't face their
own issues themselves